Well first of all it's got to be tall. If it's not tall, the building will be hit before our object is.
It's got to be conducting, if it isn't conducting, well, no charge will flow through it
and will be pretty difficult to entice lighting to strike our object, and finally it's got to be grounded.
We got to disperse all of this electrical charging energy somehow, and the way
we're going to do that is by dumping it into the earth to the ground, and so there you have it.
We've basically solved the problem, so let's go to Professor Fregonese
one more time and see what he has to say.
Franklin Benjamin idea was to discharge clouds as there is an effect called the effect of points.
Points have the property of discharging electricity, so this was Franklin's idea.
It was put in practice, but it doesn't work this way. It catches the lightning, so to say.
The explanation is a bit complicated.
It produces modifications of the electrical field and then it is important
that it conveys the electricity through a conductor avoiding the circuit through the building.
It conveys electricity to the earth so discharge it to the earth.
The earth receives the electricity of lighting because it is a very big body,
and so it can receive an extra amount of electricity.
At the time of Benjamin Franklin, it was thought as a sort of general receiver of the electricity.
There you have it. We've invented the lighting rod. Good work!
And all the lighting rod is a large conducting pole
placed in your building or on top of your building with a wire running along the side,
and it must be properly grounded, and what happens is when a storm cloud comes over head,
it draws but we can think of this as drawing positive charge up.
Really what it's doing is forcing negative charge into the earth,
but it creates a really strong electric field in this region,
and the lighting instead of striking the house--it will strike our pole and life is good.
No more buildings get burn down.
Amazing! Good work Benjamin Franklin and good work to you.